إذا كنت تعيش في مبنى سكني أو
ذهبت إلى فندق
أو مبنى كبير ، ففكر فقط في الصعود
كما لو كنت لا أعرف
ثمانية طوابق ، انظر خارج
نافذة غرفتك وتخيل فقط أن
الارتفاع قادم
إليك  لأمسك بأرضك ،
لقد نشأت وترعرعت في
المحيط ،
فأنت تعلم أن المحيط
كان ملعبًا لي منذ أن كنت طفلاً
صغيرًا ، لقد ركبنا حفنة من الأمواج المختلفة
صعودًا وهبوطًا
على ساحل المغرب ، ربما كان هناك
بعض من أفضل الأمواج.  لقد
شاهدت في
جلسات حياتي مع اثنين من أفضل
أصدقائي أن كل ما لن أنساه
أبدًا كان حقًا رحلة العمر
حتى حدث الأسوأ مطلقًا
[موسيقى]
في أي نقطة أدركت بيلي أن
الأمور تسير على نحو خاطئ
لقد اشتعلت بموجة جيدة
حقًا وقرأتها خطأً بسيطًا ارتكبت خطأً بسيطًا
ووقعت في مكان حرج حقًا
من الموجة حيث سقطت
تلك الموجة وامتصني إلى
فمها وضربتني على صخرة على
اليمين  جانب من بلدي بو  لقد
دمرتني تمامًا ، في المرة
الثانية التي ضربت فيها تلك الصخرة ، كانت الأنوار مطفأة
، وعندما جئت
إليها كانت استجابة فورية لأنني
في وضع البقاء على قيد الحياة الكامل ،
فأنا لست فقط مثل مهلاً ، أحتاج إلى مساعدة مثل
هذا
هذا صريح مثل الحياة أو الموت ،
لا يمكنك أن تنسى الألم كثيرًا ولكن
الكثير منه مجرد ضبابية بالنسبة لي أعتقد أنني
كنت أذهب وأخرج من
مجرد فرط التنفس ومنع
الألم من خلال الألم ،
أنا فقط أنا  ممتن جدًا
لوجود فريق من الأشخاص وأصدقائي
المقربين معي
لإنقاذ حياتي ، ما أثار الخوف في
اهتمامي كان مجرد التفكير في عدم
القدرة على رؤية أطفالي مرة أخرى ، لقد
فقدت أخي عندما كان عمري ثمانية أعوام
منذ سنوات قليلة مضت ، فقدت أمي
بسبب السرطان
وكانوا يعرفون أنهم كانوا كل ما
لدي ، ولم
أفهم حقًا ما كان الخوف حتى
هذه الحالة
كانت لديك مخاوف أخرى
تتجاوز صحتك المباشرة في تلك
اللحظة  هل يمكن أن تشرح لي نوع
الموقف الذي أنت
عليه الآن  تعرف على نفسك في كل شخص في العالم بأسره
أن كوفيد 19 بدأ للتو في اتخاذ إجراءات
صارمة لقد كنت في حالة
لم أستطع فيها الطيران على متن طائرة تجارية
مع حدوث كسر في الحوض إلى هذا الحد لدرجة أنك لا تستطيع
ترك
نقالة بالطريقة الوحيدة  لإعادتي إلى
الجراحة الفورية في الولايات المتحدة
كانت طائرة خاصة أعادتني
إنها مجرد قصة غير عادية إلى أي مدى
كنت قريبًا من
عدم القدرة على العودة
إلى الولايات
التي أغلقت الحدود مثل
البوابات التي
تسقط كما لو كانت حرفياً  يحدث فقط
في الدقيقة كما لو أنه لم يكن مثل
أوه غدًا أو في هذا اليوم كان الأمر كما لو كان
أوه لا ، لقد أغلقوا أغلقوا
أغلقوا أغلقوا كما لو كان الأمر
وكأننا نحاول
ضربك أعلم أن ضربهم  لكمة فقط
للحصول على دخول إلى
أرضنا ، لا يمكنك الشفاء
بنفسك وهذا شيء تعلمته
مبكرًا عما مررت به
لمجرد الوصول إلى أرضنا ،
كنت بحاجة لأن تعرف ليس أيامًا ولكني كنت بحاجة
إلى بضعة أيام  أشهر للعلاقات
العامة عقليا  أعلم نفسي وأشفى ذهني من أجل
العودة إلى لوح التزلج ، فأنا
ممتن جدًا ومحظوظًا لأهلي في
محيطي ، المجتمع الذي
رباني ،
لقد كانت رحلة برية كانت مجنونة وأنت
تعرف ما
الذي أخذته  وما تعلمته
في الصيف الماضي هو
أنك تعرف على الأرجح معرفة أكثر مما كنت سأحصل
عليه في أي وقت مضى دون
التعرض لهذه الإصابة ، لذا
في الوقت نفسه ، أقدر حقًا
هذا التعافي باعتباره نعمة مقنعة
[موسيقى]